[Music]
descendants to co-stars dove Cameron and
Thomas Doherty are the first couple who
comes to mind when we think of
relationship goals we became a little
obsessed so we found some intimate
things about the celebrity couple's
relationship that you might not know
watch until the end to find out if Dov
and Thomas are going to tie the knot
anytime soon hit that subscribe button
for the latest videos on your favorite
disney movies and shows and click that
like button if you're as obsessed with
Dov and Thomas as who we are now here
are 20 things you didn't know about dove
Cameron and Thomas Dougherty's
relationship they were friends first
dove and Thomas were close friends all
the way back when dub was still engaged
to live in Maddie co-star Ryan McCarten
windows met Thomas on the set of
descendants to she didn't think much of
it at first she said she was focused on
her own job on the film
apparently she can't even remember when
he first started to stand out to her as
someone she could fall in love with they
took things super slow and really got to
know each other first looks like it
totally paid off their chemistry almost
got their d2 scene cut you guys remember
the scene where Harry groups mal and
runs his wicked hook through her purple
hair well it almost ended up getting cut
because of their steamy chemistry even
though Harry is supposed to be all team
uma and real-life food oven Thomas
couldn't keep their eyes off each other
dev talked about the scene in an
interview with j14 she said the scene
with the hook almost got cut because the
chemistry was so intense that everyone
was wondering if the audience was going
to think that the story was about mal
and Harry we want to see that movie
their first date was at a pancake cafe
in an interview with code magazine
Thomas gushed over Deb saying she was a
wonderful human who is kind loving funny
extremely talented and has the most
beautiful eyes we think we speak for
everyone when we say oh he talked about
their first date which he says was at a
pancake cafe he said it was one of those
things where she sat across from him
drenched because it was raining outside
he said she made terrible jokes that he
was obliged to laugh at and he kind of
just fell in love with her Thomas said
that he and dev are both weird which is
why the relationship works so well Kenny
Ortega spots descendants director may
have an eye for more than just amazing
talent
looks like he played Cupid on set with
dev and Thomas dev explained that Kenny
was telling them that they can't make
their scene too intense their chemistry
was so powerful even off-camera at
rehearsals that she claims that they
were unaware of it their co-stars and
crew definitely noticed though then
Kenny came up to da band said he thought
that she and Thomas would be really good
together he's definitely not wrong if
Kenny andr quits directing she should go
into the matchmaking business then mal
and Harry back story so apparently Kenny
Ortega helped dnt come up with a
backstory for their characters the story
was that mal and Harry were each other's
first loves
she was the baddest girl and he was the
baddest guy Duff said it was sort of
like a Johnny Depp and Wynonna Ryder
thing they were madly in love with each
other but then she broke his heart which
is why Harry hates Mouse so much and
while they were together mal and Harry
got secret matching hook tattoos Duff
and Thomas would draw them under their
gloves every day the staring contest
dov says she can pinpoint the exact
moment she started falling for Thomas it
was during a staring contest they had
she said they were just staring at each
other for like ten minutes and that was
the first time they were like oh my god
I could fall for you she said they both
ended up crying their eyes started
watering and they were like woah from
that moment she felt like she just
wanted to hang out with him she said she
just wanted to be there with him she
doesn't want to do any activity just be
together so sweets taller than dove
Devon Thomas posts lots of pics of them
together they aren't shy at all about
sharing their special moments together
with the world and does not shy about
posting the specifics about Thomas's
measurements either in one Instagram
post
she wrote that Thomas is six feet tall
compared to her five foot two height
that's a pretty big difference so does
he been down when they kiss or does Duff
stand on her tippy toes she said she
doesn't really even notice the height
difference because most people are
taller than her but she appreciates that
he can carry her around and let her hide
in his jacket a little freaked out
dev shared that she remembers spilling
that sort of absolutely terrifying
feeling when you're starting to fall in
love with someone she said she was like
no
Oh dum felt like she was going downhill
with no brakes on
she was super freaked out about it
because she said nobody else could break
her heart like he could so that was
pretty scary but she's happy she
followed her heart DAF calls Thomas the
most beautiful human being on the face
of the planet
not physically she was quick to point
that out but emotionally she's not shy
about calling him the most perfect thing
under the Sun they love Bend watching a
certain TV show during rehearsals for
dissonance 3 the couple finally got a
day off together so what did they do
Tom is posted on Twitter that the couple
binge-watched season 9 of the office
together
he added that they were ruined with
crying and laughing emojis with all the
glamour and the spotlights it makes
sense that the couple would want to
spend their day off huddling in their
pajamas watching episodes of the office
great show by the way they also loved
going to hockey games and eating pasta
together and then recreating the iconic
Lady and the [ __ ] image how cute are
they
Thomas gave Doug's heart literally if
you're as big of a dump hammering fan as
we are you've probably seen her wearing
her most prized piece of jewelry on the
red carpet it's a heart locket from her
dad who passed away when she was only 15
years old well Thomas knew how much
heart jewelry meant to her so he got her
a silver heart bracelet to match they
posted a picture of the bracelet and
tags Thomas in it he shows that he had
it engraved with the nickname he calls
her Clos which is short for her actual
first name Chloe that may be the
sweetest thing we've ever seen they
co-starred together in the lodge last
year dev co-starred with her Bay on the
hit Disney UK musical series the lodge
Thomas is one of the leading stars of
the show and death appeared as a new
character named Jess Disney Channel UK
posted on Twitter that Dolph was playing
a confident and sporty character in an
upcoming episode in the show Thomas's
and dubs characters were almost Viking
partners but she chose a different mate
instead they must have still been
battling that on-screen chemistry
because the show used clever editing to
make sure the audience only saw the last
half of their on-screen hug Thomas has a
jacket with the doves face on it just
when you thought these two couldn't get
any cuter together they go and do
something like this apparently a fan
made
a jacket with a doves face on the back
which is surrounded by roses he wore it
to an event in Los Angeles in March and
then again when the couple went to
Coachella together
Doug posted a pic of him wearing it with
the caption it's his favorite jacket in
the picture he is taking a picture of
his beloved so you can see her face
twice Thomas treats her like a princess
what girl doesn't want a guy who gives
her the royal treatment
while they were working together on d3
Doug took to Twitter to post that she
just spent the last half hour
laying in her boyfriend's laughs while
they watch TV she added that he was
brushing her hair out from roots to dip
in between kisses she called her life
have it on earth and said that Thomas
Doherty treats her like a princess
later she posted a video on Instagram of
Thomas giving her a flip rub she wrote
that he just does this and called him
loverboy they tried to keep their
relationship secret at first when their
relationship was brand new the couple
tried to keep it a secret but one of
their trusted friends always knew what
was going on
Sophia Carson said that from the very
beginning there was definitely chemistry
there she said that for a while it was a
secret that Doug wanted to keep but it
was super obvious that they had feelings
for each other Sophia added that as long
as doves happy she's happy fans have
noticed and posted on Twitter that they
are loving how happy she seems now of
course a girl doesn't meet a guy to be
whole and happy but it doesn't hurt they
love to play dress-up the two whisks
themselves away for a romantic trip to
Paris and kissed with the Eiffel Tower
in the background then they went home to
play dress-up Tom has posted this
hilarious adorable video of Dov brushing
his hair and singing sweetly he sings
with her and it's too adorable for words
when she hugs him he whispers watch my
hair they also like kissing in the dark
red lipstick and off Thomas always
compliments Dov dev and Thomas are no
strangers to posting PDA pictures and
details about their love on social media
doves happy birthday insta video for
Thomas features the two of them dancing
in the wind
she wrote happy birthday to the one who
holds my heart she said the fact that he
exists is proof enough for her of
divinity and goodness this post gave us
all the fields Thomas isn't intimidated
by his award-winning girlfriend Thomas
is the epitome of the supportive
boyfriend
he rubs her feet brushes her hair and
kisses her all the time but when Dov won
a Daytime Emmy Award for outstanding
performer in a children's preschool
children's or educational and
informational program for her work on
the Disney show live in Maddy he was
right by her side now there are guys who
might be intimidated by such a talented
and successful woman
the Thomas is not one of those guys in
dubs Instagram video we see him hugging
her after her name is called and he is
all smiles no you guys she's not
pregnant
apparently some fans got a little ahead
of themselves dove Cameron shared a
sweet picture of the couple on the red
carpet at the Emmys some gossip must
have been brewing because dove felt the
need to caption her picture saying no
you guys I am not pregnant
she wrote that Thomas was just holding
her body close in an intimate way she
added that she would not be so chill
about it when she announces she is
pregnant in about ten years or more
still it's fun to imagine what their
baby would look like well the baby have
doves eyes and Thomas's chiseled jawline
what do you guys think they're real
matching tattoos in an interview with
j14 dove talks about their real matching
tattoos dev said that the reason she
wanted the tattoo originally was because
of her favorite musical the light in the
Piazza there's a lyric that she loves
that says I know what the sunlight can
be for dove that means knowing the pain
and pleasures of the world she believes
the sunlight represents life in
everything that life encompasses she
said for Thomas the tattoo represents
coming out of dark times and being
positive but she admits that they really
got it because they wanted to match are
they engaged you know what Beyonce said
if you like it put a ring on it well it
just so happens that dove confessed her
desire to marry Thomas and it was at the
Beyonce performance at Coachella she
posted the video of him dancing to
Beyonce's who run the world and she
quoted him as saying bow down and dance
to the women mates one band posted a
comment on the vid honestly marry him
dev responded I'm gonna there is no
official news of an engagement yet but
it sure seems like it's in their
inevitable future and that was 20 things
you didn't know about dove chairman and
Thomas Daugherty's relationship thanks
for watching the things bye
[Music]